friday's drone strike that killed two
isil k members and wounded another was
the first retaliatory strike against the
group but according to president joe
biden it won't be the last it's unclear
if those killed had a direct role in
thursday's airport attack that killed
over 150 afghans and over a dozen u.s
military personnel
the pentagon won't release the names of
the isil k members they killed only
saying they were planning future attacks
i am not going to talk about
specific capabilities isis may have lost
in this strike they lost a planner and
they lost a facilitator and they've got
one wounded
and the fact that two of these
individuals are no long longer walking
on the face of the earth that's a good
thing it's a good thing for the people
of afghanistan it's a good thing for our
troops and our forces at that airfield
and i think i'm just going to leave it
there
while the u.s and the taliban are
coordinating on airport security that
cooperation did not extend to the drone
strike
a taliban spokesperson told reuters news
agency they should have been informed
before the air strike took place
in a statement saturday afternoon biden
said the chance of another terrorist
attack in the next 24 to 36 hours is
very high it's believed around 4 000 u.s
troops are still at the airport in kabul
and commanders say despite the risks the
mission continues until the august 31st
deadline biden has put in place
threats to our forces and to this
operation remain real and significant
i'm sure you can appreciate that and now
as the military mission trend begins to
end in kabul thousands of service
members are working across the globe and
within the united states to complete
this incredibly important mission
caught in the middle innocent afghan
civilians at an airport near washington
on saturday afghan evacuees continued to
arrive in america after an arduous
journey
well i would say
last six or seven days have been the
toughest days of my life honestly i
don't want to lie or i don't want to
exaggerate but
it is how it is
things are really bad
all around the airport all the entrances
and
you kind of feel lucky if you can get
just through those gates
over the weekend america was learning
more of the u.s service members killed
in the suicide attack
max soviet a navy medic was one of them
he was only two years old when the u.s
invaded afghanistan in 2001.
friends and family back in his hometown
of ohio are grieving his death
he was just a really
good kid and
you know that everybody liked everybody
loves the family
just very
well respected
the u.s military pullout from
afghanistan was measured in months and
then weeks and now it's down to days and
it could be the most unpredictable and
dangerous phase of all
with president biden simultaneously
warning americans that there could be
more attacks against u.s troops in kabul
while also more strikes against those
the u.s says is responsible
gabriel lozando al jazeera
washington